nous en tout cas on a réussi à tirer
notre épingle du jeu c'est vraiment le
soir et à la rigueur nous c'est
peut-être pas comme les autres on a une
position stratégique c'estd on est
vraiment au carrefour de tous les hôtels
donc c'est pour ça mais je dis ça a
compensé la diminution de tourisme sur
la région
voilà on sur adap aux
Américains parce entre guillemets on a
réussi a réussi nous avons eu beaucoup
de délégations américaines qui sont venu
dès les premiers jours ils ont d
apprécier notre car si bien que et ben
au bout de 3 4 jours on s'est mis à
faire des burgers Normands toujours é-il
avec bon du cambber du chère des
produits locaux tout en mettant en avant
aussi le cidre donc chose qu'on ne fait
pas habituellement tout au long de
l'année c'est vrai que c'est pas le
cidre qui part forcément le plus là en
revche les Américains si ont une vraie
demande de de cidre de produits locaux
mais restent attachés à leur à leur
burgers et et surtout tout ce qui est
grillable viande grillée donc là
installé en cuisine exprès pour eux pour
les de semaines une pierre de lerve donc
c'est comme on s cur une viande notentre
côte comme si c'était au barbecue donc
on retrouve le goût du barbecue tout en
ayant la possibilité de le faire
derrière